After becoming so invested in the story and
characters, it's hard to move on from Game
of Thrones.
But the producers, writers, and actors behind
the series have left Westeros behind for new
projects, and it looks like there's no going
back.
Here's why you shouldn't expect a Game of
Thrones sequel anytime soon.
Ready for a season nine of Game of Thrones?
What about a tenth?
HBO President of Programming Casey Bloys is
on record as having been willing to back many
more seasons of the smash hit series.
But instead of forcing the show to continue
indefinitely, he allowed the creative team
to make the ultimate decision regarding when
it would end.
Apparently, showrunners David Benioff and
D.B. Weiss knew how they wanted the ending
to go for a long time, and Bloys let them
wrap things up on their terms.
And that ending, it seems, is pretty definitive.
When asked about potential sequel series that
may be in the works, Bloys told The Hollywood
Reporter:
"Nope, nope, nope.
No.
Part of it is, I do want this show...to be
its own thing.
I don't want to take characters from this
world that they did beautifully and put them
off into another world with someone else creating
it."
In other words, don't hold out hope for that
Arya Goes West spinoff.
Author George R.R. Martin is supposed to be
working diligently on The Winds of Winter,
but he's also found time to publish several
books plotting out hundreds of years of Westerosi
history.
There is a wealth of material set in the past,
and HBO has flirted with adapting more than
a few stories for television.
"If we forget where we've been, what we've
done, we're not men anymore.
We're just animals."
Of the possible projects, one prequel series
is definitely moving ahead with a pilot being
filmed and an announced cast list that includes
Naomi Watts and Josh Whitehouse.
The as-yet unnamed prequel series will take
place thousands of years before the events
of Game of Thrones as it chronicles the world’s
descent from the golden Age of Heroes into
its darkest hour.
There's little word on the other projects
in development, which may well never come
to fruition.
But if one spinoff proves successful, chances
are more will follow.
Further prequels could follow the events of
Martin's Fire & Blood, which details how King
Aegon the Dragon conquered Westeros with his
royal sisters.
Another prequel series could also adapt some
of the tales collected in the short story
volume A Knight of the Seven Kingdoms, which
follow a towering hedge knight named Duncan,
who's an ancestor of Brienne of Tarth, travelling
with and defending a little Targaryen prince
by the name of Aegon V, or simply "Egg."
There's still more material in Westeros' history
that seems perfect for television: the Blackfyre
Rebellions, the Targaryen civil war, the dark
tale of the Night's King.
And that's just events from Westeros.
Essos has a long and storied history too.
When it comes to stories set in the past,
Martin has given HBO quite a bit to work with.
Game of Thrones viewers became accustomed
to the visual splendor of each episode over
the course of eight seasons.
Each episode is like its own full-fledged
film, brought to life with reality-defying
special effects, lavish costuming, sets built
to scale, and massive casts of extras.
As you might imagine, filming a season's worth
of small movies can get pretty expensive.
The final season reportedly cost an estimated
$15 million per episode.
It takes a lot of money to make dragons fly,
direwolves growl, and wights reanimate.
HBO can afford to make entire series for $15
million rather than shelling out $15 million
for a single episode.
Another Game of Thrones-scale series, especially
one that brought back the same increasingly-expensive
cast members, might be a bit too much of a
financial burden to be worth mounting.
"It wasn't just about the money, was it?
Was it?…Was it?"
As the final credits roll on Game of Thrones,
a new era begins.
High fantasy has proven itself to be extremely
profitable, so HBO and the BBC have teamed
up to make another fantasy show based on a
beloved book series: His Dark Materials.
Political struggles?
Check.
Mysterious powers?
CGI animals?
Check.
It isn't a Game of Thrones sequel, but it
may satisfy some of the same viewers who tuned
in to watch the fantasy unfold.
Plus, if you're tired of fantasy lands, there
are plenty of other shows that HBO has cooking
that explore different genres.
Westworld has another season on the way, for
those of the convoluted sci-fi loving persuasion.
Fans of superheroes and contemplative graphic
novels can rejoice in the upcoming premiere
of the Watchmen adaptation.
Jordan Peele and JJ Abrams are producing Lovecraft
Country, a horror drama that's almost guaranteed
to be a hit.
Even now that we're done watching Thrones,
there are plenty of shows on the way that
will make your HBO subscription worth it.
Even before the dust settled on Game of Thrones,
showrunners D.B. Weiss and David Benioff set
their sights on a galaxy far, far away.
Disney CEO Bob Iger has confirmed that after
the twin suns set on the current trilogy of
Star Wars films, Benioff and Weiss will be
working on the next series of films, a trilogy
telling a new story separate from the Skywalker
saga.
The first of the three films is due at the
end of 2022, giving audiences plenty of time
to forget how upset they were at the final
Game of Thrones season.
With two of the largest creative engines for
Game of Thrones headed to space, it doesn't
seem like a Thrones sequel is in the cards,
at least not from them.
Game of Thrones has changed television as
we know it.
It's no longer satisfactory for shows to be
small with dedicated followings.
Every show wants to be a blockbuster, and
in the coming years, there will be no limit
to the number of titles seeking to fill the
void that the end of Game of Thrones has left
in our hearts.
His Dark Materials isn't the only fantasy
adaptation on the table.
Netflix is launching a series based on The
Witcher series of books, which has previously
been adapted into a very successful video
game franchise.
Amazon reportedly paid close to $250 million
for a Lord of the Rings prequel series.
Meanwhile, Netflix is also planning a live-action
version of the beloved animated series Avatar:
The Last Airbender.
Every major company is trying to replicate
the GoT success, and with a competition that
crowded, it's unlikely that a Game of Thrones
sequel would really stand out.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.